i'm sorry is something wrong will you
seem upset i'm okay i don't want to talk
about it
i've known you a long time i've never
seen you like this what's the problem
well i don't know if you follow the news
at all um
but there's this actress
uh
kristen stewart okay
and um
she goes by k-stew
and uh
she goes by k-state yeah and um she had
a boyfriend right and
robert patterson and uh he's our past
and um he's okay
and
and she cheated on him
and they're broken up they're not going
to get back together ever
um
what they had was so special conan you
don't even know what they had they were
they were in love
and
and she just threw it all away
okay and i
i just i don't know if there was
anything i could have done to prevent it
or
i don't know what it means to the
twilight franchise i just don't know
i'm just i'm i'm i'm i will i'm sure
it's gonna be fine it's not gonna be
fine ever
never gonna be fine
what they had was so special you don't
even know
you would never know well you don't
never know i've been in love no it's not
like them
not like them
never seen you she is a trampire that's
what she is
[Applause]